[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
halloween steht ja wieder fast vor der
tür und ich habe mir gedacht machen wir
wieder eine motiv torte und das war
jetzt echt ein zufall aber ich habe mir
wirklich überlegt den joker zu machen
aus dem film batman und einfach das
gesicht zu machen ganz einfach zum
nachmachen und dann kommt der frank und
sagt es ist ja kommt doch auch der film
raus also habe ich gedacht laden wird
das video etwas früher hoch denn ich
glaube diese woche sogar oder nächste
woche kommt der film in die kinos mit
joker und ich werde diese torte machen
ich mache jetzt einen ganz normalen
kuchen ihr könnt euer lieblingsrezept
verwenden zitrone chor und schokokuchen
ganz egal welchen kuchen
ich mach jetzt einen mandelkuchen mit
bisschen marzipan geschmack aber wenn
ihr sagt mir schmeckt mir nicht ganz so
gut dann guckt einfach auf meinem blog
nach da gibt es wirklich ganz viele
verschiedene rezepte für den rührteig
verwende ich 200 gramm weiche butter 200
gramm zucker und eine prise salz 100
gramm marzipanrohmasse etwas
bittermandel aroma feier die sind zimmer
war 200 gramm mandeln die werde ich
gleich noch einmal 200 gramm mehl ein
päckchen backpulver das sind drei
teelöffel und 125 gramm lauwarme milch
die mandeln werde jetzt fragen wir mal
und ich meinte immer gerne besser weil
sie so das aroma richtig schön noch mit
drin haben schmecken aromatischer
wenn ihr die mandeln dann gemahlen habt
könnt ihr bereits den rührteig
herstellen
jetzt einfach die butter mit dem zucker
verrühren prise salz noch dazu es gebe
zum verstärken das amaretto geschmacks
also dass man den geschmack noch ein
paar tropfen bittermandel aroma dazu
jetzt hier für etwa zwei bis drei
minuten verrühren oder vier bis fünf bis
es eben schön weiß cremig ist
nämlich das marzipan ohne spezielle
smartpen form von unserem alpaka freuen
und das hier ist jetzt mal mit geschmack
mit bösen bösen bären sich zumindest
richtig gut wird auch verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen und das tue ich
jetzt so ein stück von früher ist
einfach so etwa eine minute in den teig
unser alpaka freund das wetter wieder
hin
[Musik]
jetzt geht es ja nacheinander die eier
dazu immer eine halbe minute einrühren
und dann erst das nächste
so gewinnt der rührteig alles zusammen
mit dem thema warm sein das ist immer
das wichtigste wenn man ein rührteig mit
butter macht
das mädel pavillon mit dem backpulver so
verteilt ist nämlich schön und jetzt
kommt alles machen
und jetzt wirklich nur noch kurz
früheren sonst wird daten nämlich stecke
ich die menschen ist auch lauwarmen das
mehl dazu und die mandeln
das ist so die größte fehlerquelle
beiträgt dass der teig einfach überhört
wird das heißt sobald mir dabei ist
wirklich nicht mehr lange röhren und
dann kommt er direkt in den rhein
den habe ich bereits auf 24 zentimeter
durchmesser eingestellt und dann so ein
bisschen verteilen und ich streiche den
teig immer gerne am rand etwas hoch so
backer gleichmäßiger
[Musik]
und solange dates im ofen backen kann
ich mich schon mal um die creme kümmern
die torte werde ich mit einer marmelade
füllen und einer garage da mache ich
jetzt einfach eine zahl tag danach und
zwar dicker nach zum befüllen
das heißt 300 gramm sahne und 600 gramm
zucker schokolade die sahne wird jetzt
einmal kurz aufgekocht
dann schalte ich den herd aus und dann
ruhig die schokolade ein
jetzt schauen dass die schokolade schön
in der sahne ist ein zwei minuten warten
und rühren und die creme werde ich dann
auch gleich umfüllen und luftdicht
verschließen hier auf der arbeitsplatte
also bei zimmertemperatur abkühlen
lassen und der kuchen der wandert dann
in den kühlschrank natürlich schön
eingepackt dann wird man nicht trocknet
und da mache ich nämlich morgen weiter
ja so kann man sich das immer schön ein
teil jedes mal denke ich so lässt sich
die moderation fertig dann fällt mir
wieder was ein
dann denke ich jetzt ist sie fertig also
ich teile mir das jetzt schön ein heute
habe ich die vorbereitung gemacht und
morgen mache ich dann die torte fertig
hat aus ende
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der moment an dem wir euch
einen joker aus suchen müsst also alle
die jetzt angst vom yoga haben gute
werden die tochter ist gar nicht
anklicken
am besten sucht ihr euch ein gesicht aus
was portal ist das heißt ich habe jetzt
ein gegeben bei google einfach pokerface
habe jetzt das hier gefunden das ihr
euch an heath ledger komplett ihr könnt
aber auch so eine comicfigur nehmen die
zwei habe ich jetzt hier auf interest
gefunden
ich muss dazu sagen die gefällt mir ganz
gut allerdings ist dies ein bisschen
flach also wenn ihr ein bisschen
einfacher retorte machen wollt nehmt ihr
die hier nämlich weniger falten
ich nehme jetzt den hier und der frank
der leg magic art in photoshop noch
augen rein das heißt so kann ich später
noch die augen machen ja die figur
nämlich wenn ich ein jogger denkt denkt
ich halt einfach an diese figur
ja und ich habe batman damals einfach
nur die kurze wegen heath ledger so wie
ihm ging es auch sowie der hand nach
oben
er war halt auch echt ein guter joker ja
was ich nicht machen kann und nicht
machen werde ist eine ist heute also ein
clown denn ich finde es schon geschehen
etwas gruselig aber der joker das geht
denn das war schlecht aber das auch
geklärt
ich nehme jetzt hier den kuchen heraus
der ist schön abgekühlt habe ihn direkt
im ring abkühlen lassen
einmal auslösen
[Musik]
und die schablone druckt ihr euch jetzt
so aus dass von der größe her zu eurem
kuchen passt und ich schneide sie jetzt
noch eben auch perfekt jetzt nämlich
hier die garage habe einen cache bord
und da kommt jetzt ein bisschen ganache
drauf damit der kuchen schön hält zum
film schneide ich den kuchen jetzt mal
durch und dann nimmt er entweder torten
säge oder einfach eine totenmesse
[Musik]
der erste wurden kommt jetzt direkt
drauf
jetzt könnt ihr ihn entweder komplett
mit der garage füllt oder noch eine
marmelade nehmen ich nehme die zähne
creme die ich gemacht habe für die
hochzeitstorte meiner freundin lisa das
ist eine kirsch marzipan krämer also ein
amarena kirsch creme da kommt das rezept
demnächst online
aber wie gesagt könnt ihr hier gerne
einfach nun aber lade aufnehmen das
passt jetzt hier geschmackliche echt
ganz gut und es hat echt immer super
wichtig dass torten nicht nur gut
aussehen sondern in erster linie gut
schmecken
das heißt nehmt euch wirklich auch die
zeit für die füllung trinkt sie gerne
auch mit einem likör zum beispiel oder
erwärmt die marmelade mit dem likör
damit einfach die torte nicht trocken
wird sondern saftig wird eine schicht
darüber
[Musik]
die gesamte torte füllen
perfekt so kommt jetzt erst mal in den
kühlschrank damit die ganz schön fest
wird und die torte gleich zurecht
schneiden kann die ghanaer skript echt
gut ich schiebe den kuchen jetzt weiter
runter wegen den haar wissen
er klebt jetzt gleich wieder fest dass
nämlich die vorlage jetzt habe ich sie
mittlerweile mit augen
okay es ist schon ein bisschen gruselig
aus aber es ist ja nur geschminkt okay
das make up ist in schwarz und fertig
aber im film waren echt sympathisch ok
jetzt stehe ich hier einmal außen herum
und hier oben fehlt ein stück aber das
setzt sich einfach du mit diesem stück
hier wieder an
[Musik]
überall da wo etwas an leben wollt nehmt
ihr einfach danach stieß zum einen
lecker und zum anderen dient sie eben
als kleber
das heißt hier fehlt jetzt ein bisschen
der haaransatz und haartransplantation
[Musik]
das jetzt war der moment an dem man
denkt okay es wird nie eine richtig
coole tortur aber doch es wird eine
coole torte geht es jetzt kurz fest
werden und dann kann ich wieder weiter
schmelzen
die restlich habe ich mal noch auf denn
es kann sein dass ich die noch brauchen
und wir nicht kann man später fand eine
vorlage lasse ich jetzt hier ganz die
andere habe ich bisher zerschnitten
ich muss jetzt nämlich das gesicht von
den haaren abheben das heißt ich lege
mir das gesicht hin schneide einmal hier
vorsichtig drumherum
ich möchte ja das ist wirklich schön
dreidimensional aussieht das heißt die
haare hier an der seite die werde ich
etwas nach hinten schneiden
also hier ein bisschen was an masse
wegnehmen wenn ihr euch noch
verschnitten habt ist gar nicht schlimm
denn ihr könnt ihr einfach immer wieder
was dran setzen und das gesicht ist
natürlich in der mitte bei der nase am
höchsten und geht dann auch so ein
bisschen nach außen
das ist jetzt echt großartig und die
augen schneide
aber hey ist es nur ein kuchen
und überall da wo ich markante
gesichtszüge habe schneide ich sie
natürlich ein
[Musik]
die augen so ein bisschen ausholen
das gesicht hier nach außen abrunden
[Musik]
und die garage hier nehme ich jetzt um
das ganze dreidimensionale formen um zu
glätten das heißt ich streiche immer
wieder auf sie ein bisschen tag drauf
schneider respekt und so entsteht jetzt
gleich die gesichtsform die erste
schicht garage ist jetzt schon mal drauf
die ersten gesichtszüge stehen schon
jetzt können auch noch shakespeare
werden
ich kann mich nur um entscheiden aber
ich stelle die torte erstmal einen
kühlschrank damit die ganz fest wird und
ich dann etwas einfacher daran arbeiten
kann
jetzt geht es schon direkt an die
feinheiten das heißt mit der garage
versuche ich jetzt das gesicht zu
glätten
noch ein bisschen struktur reinzubringen
und stammen kommen wir dem ganzen 10er
[Musik]
nämlich immer wieder die vorlage legte
hier drauf und können jetzt hier auch
schon mal die linien markieren und habe
jetzt hier noch etwas modelle marzipan
also dekor marzipan
da ist jetzt egal welche farbe ihr nehmt
und damit könnt ihr nämlich gesichtszüge
und die nase zum beispiel richtig gut
formen
ich werde jetzt erst mal benutzten für
die wangen das nämlich auch noch ein
bisschen zu flach das heißt neben ein
kleines stück in die hand schau immer
wieder auf die vorlage platziere ist
dann einfach mit den händen schön
drücken könnte auch modelle werkzeug
dafür benutzten die höchste stelle
direkt hier am wangenknochen und der
grinst ja immer so ganz typisch das
heißt es grinsen kommt auch gleich noch
dazu und schiebt die wange so ein
bisschen nach außen
[Musik]
ist ja auch die unterlippe mit anbringen
ist die nase dran und dafür nehme ich
auch ein stück marzipan legt sie auf die
vorlage so erstmals hier vorne die
nasenspitze jetzt dass ich noch etwas
seltsam aus aber gleich mit der von dann
schicht darüber wird gleich gut los ist
einfach nur die markanten gesichtszüge
heraus stechen lassen oder mit
[Musik]
theoretisch könnt ihr jetzt auch fondant
nehmen zum formen
aber ich find s bahn einfach viel viel
leckerer deswegen habe ich ihr marzipan
die commerzbank dennoch schönen flachen
nasenrücken hat schon eine schöne nase
jetzt an einigen stellen einfach noch
mal mit ghana strüber um diese lücken
und diese übergänge zu glätten
[Musik]
durch größtenteils alles vorerst fertig
ich werde jetzt noch mal kühl stellen
dann nochmal alle unebenheiten
ausgleichen und dann geht schon an die
deko
[Musik]
ich freue mich hier auf der seite noch
den haaransatz das heißt ich mache den
scheitel so wie auf dem bild und um den
haaransatz und entscheide zu verstärken
nämlich auch hier wieder etwas marzipan
legt es hier direkt rein und form grad
so ein paar strenge in die richtung und
so bekomme ich schon mal so einen
schönen dreidimensionalen effekt und da
kann man gleich die folgenden decke
drüber und ich habe es wirklich ein
bisschen einfacher beim formen
[Musik]
ich glaube immer im nächsten leben ganz
ehrlich ich habe schon oft gesagt ich
werde
schönheitschirurgie dann mache ich aus
allem
hahahaha
[Musik]
du kommst jetzt in den kühlschrank das
war die hexe machen
ich will keinen erschrecken
ok wertes der sondern dran
ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen weiß
und grün und weiß habe ich jetzt bereits
reich geknetet denn damit fange ich an
und ich rolle jetzt den von dann auf
etwas becker stärke aus nicht ganz so
dünn wie normalerweise denn ich möchte
ja noch ein bisschen struktur rein
bringen und muss noch ein bisschen
modellieren
daher darf davon ein bisschen dicker
bleiben was sonst
[Musik]
diese abstands rädchen dran und dann
habe ich eine schöne gleichmäßige stärke
[Applaus]
er ist 3 mm dick nämlich die torte
gespräche mit back prince bringt damit
davon dann doch hält aber erstmal nur da
wo das gesicht ist das ist nur übers
gesicht legen denn die haare die werden
der gleich grün den fingern schön hier
entlang
schneidet sie am haaransatz entlang
kannst du vorsichtig lieber erstmal
bisschen mehr dran lassen als zu viel
wegschneiden
jetzt nämlich modell ihr werkzeug und
geht es hier einfach komplett in die
falten rhein wird die nase schön aus
modellieren und da brauchte einfach ein
bisschen geduld aber ihr detaillierter
umso besser
[Musik]
hat hier so die falten am auge die sind
natürlich auch ganz ganz wichtig und da
nehme ich einfach dieses spitzenmodelle
werkzeug setzt hier in der mitte an und
ziehen nach außen und je tiefer ist als
ihr fester gedrückt um so tiefere falten
[Musik]
der weiße bart ist jetzt vollendet ich
habe jetzt alle tiefen falten gezogen
das stelle ich die tore kurz zur seite
und kann etwas grün ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt werde die torte leicht besprühen
und ich mache jetzt erst mal die seite
des scheitels und dann die kleine seite
gut überlegen der von dort lässt sich
auch echt gut ziehen
das schön elastisch verbauter sehr gut
[Musik]
es regt mich am besten ein tuch zu recht
denn immer wenn ich hier etwas schneidet
man etwas ghanas am messer ist dann
bitte wieder einfach schön sauber machen
damit die torte sauber bleibt
die feinheiten schneide ich dann mit dem
kater weg mit dem scharfen messer
[Musik]
seht mal ganz gut aus es kommt noch eine
haarsträhne die hängt ihm ja so ein
bisschen ins gesicht
die fängt hier hinten an kommt herüber
[Musik]
und die wird jetzt natürlich auch noch
etwas strukturiert wird das mache ich
erstmal hier
[Musik]
mit islam kleber kann ich jetzt die
strähne noch am leben
[Musik]
wir haben gerade einheitlich beschlossen
dass der joker gar keiner braucht ja ich
lasse ihnen jetzt einfach so denn er hat
einfach die haare nach vorne gekämpft
und essen und dran
außerdem muss der eh nix hören deswegen
mache ich jetzt noch eine haarsträhne
hin und dann geht schon direkt los mit
dem schockieren und ich habe jetzt hier
auch noch einige haarsträhnen dazu
gemacht sieht einfach echter aus und
nochmal voluminöser und
dreidimensionaler ich erinnere mich bei
solchen arbeiten immer gerne an meine bk
lehrerin die gesagt hat sarah mit dieser
modelle kommst du nicht weiter als im
kindergarten 3 gegeben für meine
spongebob schwammkopf unterwasserwelt
aus ton und hat gesagt ich erreicht
damit nichts und es hat mich damals als
jugendlicher echt fertig gemacht
was lehrt uns das egal wie absurd ist
sich auch anhört egal wie absurd es
vielleicht im ersten moment aussieht auf
an sich seit 2000 richter motivation
spruch 'wenn es mega absolute stand lass
es lieber wenn die mehrheit der menschen
sagt lars dass es auch aber auch sonst
inhalt an einem tollen fest
[Musik]
nämlich schwarzem pulver farbe und stadt
ihre jetzt damit das gesicht und ich
glaube da wird es richtig gruselig wird
es nur mit den augen an das heißt hier
auch so den flauschigen die trockenen
pinsel die farbe auftragen und erstmal
immer ganz wenig nach butter und kann
man immer noch
[Musik]
dann einen dünnen trockene pinsel nehmen
und damit könnt ihr hier schön die
falten so ein bisschen umfahren
dann sehen die einfach viel viel tiefer
aus werden sie dunkeln sind
[Musik]
wie kann ich euch mal zeigen was für ein
krasser unterschied ist zwischen ohne
bruder und mit bruder also ohne bruder
saß schon relativ cool aus aber ich
glaube mit puder das übertrifft einfach
links da könnt ihr wirklich so tolle
schatten rein machen und effekte und das
solltet ihr auf jeden fall die zeit
solltet ihr auf jeden fall investieren
also ich mache das jetzt hier noch
fertig ich habe auch noch rotes bruder
damit gehe ich gleich an den mund
[Musik]
die tap so kann sie schon als halloween
torte durchgehen aber ich mache jetzt
macht die augen dran
ich habe hier ein bisschen blüten pasta
und von dort vermischt weil blüten
passte einfach schön fest wird beim
aushärten und das freue mich jetzt hier
zu einer kugel dann etwas länglich das
besitzt die auch neue ausfüllen nicht zu
groß sein dann etwas klee war ein fast
überall schwarz aber ist nicht schlimm
denn da ist ja ein bisschen schmutzig
[Musik]
den rest habe ich jetzt mit schwarzer
lebensmittelfarbe komplett schwarz und
da kann ich nämlich außenrum noch das
augenlid legen so dass wirklich der
augapfel schäden im auge eingebettet ist
ja da wird plötzlich zur optikerin
augenärzte macht eine augen-op jetzt ein
bisschen verpasste in schwarz das wird
hier ein geknetet jetzt nehme ich eine
loch thüle damit markiere ich mir jetzt
erstmal die stelle mit den augen und der
guckt ja schon ein bisschen böse also so
hin sobald die er ist nicht so in der
mitte ist sondern so guckt mal einfach
böse also machen wir das jetzt auch so
ich meine ich freue mich keine richtigen
augenlider sondern ich leg dem einfach
hier ein bisschen was unter die augen
über die augen zuhalten rein und fertig
[Musik]
und damit zum luft passt hier auch mit
schwarzem pulver farbe drüber gehen
[Musik]
hier ins innere kommt noch ein bisschen
rot und dann die iris mit etwas braun
und da nehme ich jetzt einfach verpasste
oder ihr könnt einfach pulfer farbe
nehmen und die mit alkohol oder mit
wasser oder mit kokos vermischen
[Musik]
burke fährst du mir schon ziemlich gut
das einzige was ich jetzt noch machen
sind die lichtpunkte die mache ich jetzt
mit der zucker schrift in weiß und dann
können die torte anschneiden einigen
grad so findest du es nicht traurig weil
ich die täter gleich anschneiden muss
aber mein lieber schwan hat heute nacht
nicht mehr im kühlschrank haben ihre
liebe anschneiden und auflösen
[Musik]
auftritt des falls die jungs kommen muss
ich sagen der joker sieht aus als wäre
er müde da es sieht nicht böse aus es
sieht müde aus
vielleicht sollte ich meine sonnenbrille
aufsetzen naja wollt ihr kommen und
probieren okay okay geht der jogger
wieder auf es sieht freundlich
wir wissen ja freundlich als
hinterlistig sein
ja ich glaube man kann ihn sogar die
nase schäfer ja gerade nase brechen
doch schnell wird man ihn an ob ihr
wollt ihr was die optik sagen fiel von
dort also ich sehe wie bei jeder motiv
torte oder kuchen den du machst hat der
glitzer natürlich nicht fehlen gehöre
ich zu meiner entschuldigung es war
glitter auf dem pinsel
ich hab selber gemerkt dass gletscher
draufgabe aber ich meine zeit gehört auf
einer torte auf eine halloween
ja ich meine erste gemacht also
geschmeidig die jetzt an
ich mag männer hatte hier eigentlich die
narben tun kannst du musst so
wegschmeißen
hunderte sondern bestimmt aber was
michael gohla dem einfach zu voll rein
zu schneiden
hallo es ist eine halloween torte
mit dem film
von 2000 bis sie wollte schon immer mal
die wange von joker es okay
mit max kern marzipan ja ich habe aber
nur marzipan unter dem fondant im teig
von den decken also ob es wirklich kann
wenn ich für einen hersteller ist oder
dicker nach sechs jahre
aber du machst machst du panja spielt
mutig man hat ihn oder man echte stürmer
gespielt hast feinschmecker von der
geschicht alles raus was über joker
sagen also finde schon dass du ihn gut
getroffen haben ja aber danke jetzt geht
es mir besser ist der vielleicht bin ich
heute auch einfach nur traurig weil der
morath heute gegangene für sieben tage
ok eigentlich bist du wirklich darum wir
können jetzt jeden tag gehen ruhe
arbeiten
ich wollte einfach ja ich bin wirklich
traurig ja also kurz zum inhalt schweigt
minister lecker aber gar nicht so mal zu
kommen was ich dachte also muss es
probieren
aber ich glaube wirklich mein du magst
man vielleicht schmeckt ist es nicht so
raus gestern haben wir nämlich eine
linsensuppe gemacht mit sarah ich und
sie hat die so aus der app gemacht nein
und ich mag keinen weißen pfeffer und
salz pfeffer rein und zwar echte und
vieles war für euch eine prise pfeffer
aber ich habe in der 3 liter super raus
geschmeckt dass weißer pfeffer drin war
weil ich den geruch einfach nicht wahr
dass gäste war schon überrascht
wenn man etwas nicht mag muss raus ja
also ich hab damals wie gesagt batman
nur angeguckt wegen heath ledger
mittlerweile gibt es an anderen joker
das heißt der schauspieler hat sich ja
muss der andere ist halt nicht mehr und
sollte deswegen ja ich habe hier ist
leider nicht so gut getroffen aber ich
finde man erkennt das ist der job keinen
ort an dem lippenstift
ja es ist ja und ich habe und ich glaube
selbst wenn man kein batman ist oder
kein joker für eine halloween torte ist
es auf jeden fall falls sie ausprobieren
wollt findet ihr das rezept noch mal
ganz genau und schritt für schritt in
meiner app oder auf dem blog alles
natürlich kostenlos könnt euch gerne
anschauen nachmachen und mich verlinken
und wer kein marzipan markt tauscht wie
gesagt ganz gerne aus also viel spaß und
bis zum nächsten mal
und falls ihr noch halloween ideen sehen
wollt dann schreibt sie gerne dann mache
ich es gerne feucht nach oder hat für
euch und ihr macht mach ich war verwirrt
lippenstift das war pulver farbe geben
sie mir das ist sondern genau und das
habe ich so drauf gepudert aus mit dem
effekt mit dem schwarzen polo vor dem
rot jetzt schauen ganz cool und die
hausmittel
die haare sind also die haare finde ich
mega chores sowie drin
[Musik]